welcome back to CBS this morning inside
the White House and you never know who's
going to stop by here in the East Room
first daughter an assistant to the
president I'm on their trail you crash
your beautiful filming everybody sorry
had you stuck your head in the door you
took my Easter eggs are so good within
seconds I was miked I'm seated and I
just wanted to come by with a cup of
coffee to say hello no how am I like in
Washington I love it here actually it
has been an adjustment for our family
but but it's actually a really lovely
place to live and it is incredible the
there's space which is nice I think in
in New York you you lack that with our
Rock Creek Park or there's just you feel
you can be outdoors a little bit more
every night late at night no I don't see
him as much so for sure so we make we
make the time we're together account
that late last night Jared and I went
for a walk around the mall and it was so
beautiful so with the Lincoln Memorial
and just to figure out they're walking
around the mall yeah it was great um we
had sneakers and and and baseball caps
and it was amazing so we're really we're
trying to explore this new environment
in new city and and really sort of
interact with it and enjoy it mrs. Bush
used to do that she used to go on the
Washington Mall people didn't know so
you can sneak away it's a boy I know and
I've been doing a lot of it I've been
you know I made a date with Arabella we
have a standing date toes you know
interesting every week
she's almost 6:00 in July so we uh
whether it's visiting the Supreme Court
or going to one of the amazing
Smithsonian museums there's really a lot
to do and I think there's a lot to do in
New York as well but I think when you've
grown up in a place you actually take it
for granted a little bit more so we've
been having fun well now you have cats
in the back you know I have a swing
connected your biggest backyard is a big
deal now getting a dog very trail it's a
tiny backyard but it works your biggest
fan is peeking around the core
over there but it's your husband I think
you are hearing the same thing is gonna
happen to you
all right she just said Jared she just
said Oh Jared you cannot say anything
used to so Jared I walked into this room
and within 30 seconds
I was Mike could we please get a
microphone to mr. go-getter
so in panic Karen welcome to CBS this
morning yes your first birthday
interview on CBS this morning
Gerry tell us about the walk on the mall
last night with your wife great company
a beautiful scenery keep working this
way oh good work major thank you
anybody else in the family might want to
come down we can place a swallow - yeah
one more are you out there
no Ivanka if I thought that I wouldn't
be handcuffed I'd like to walk up the
steps and say hello mr. president we're
downstairs we're downstairs it's pretty
special
yeah what is it like for you though in
the way doesn't we were saying that just
a history in the room no matter who you
are when you come in here you cannot
feel I feel blase about being in this
building what it represents no that's
exactly right and and it doesn't wear
off the experience is really no less
intense and exhilarating today as it was
three months ago
so there's this history you find
yourself standing at a window and
thinking how many presidents and first
ladies and families had looked through
that same piece of glass over the course
of of this building's history and it's
really it's it fills you with awe and
Wonder and exciting a sense of this
great nation absolutely out in the
balcony this morning and looking at and
there was a wifed environment and there
was a Jefferson Memorial yes it our
country it's true it's true it's it's
hard not to feel tremendous pride
all that America's achieved and also
what's - what's to come
and now you get to work for yes and it's
a great honor and a privilege I never
thought I would be in this situation but
I'm humbled by the opportunity to make a
positive impact one one thing we we want
to invite you back here for serious
conversations about what you do I would
love to be sort of come true to sit down
respect and yes very just wanted to have
you talk about Washington but at another
time we'd love to have you back a lot
serious conversation about the country
in his future and bring Jerry to Koecher
- I really like you Eli the great edge
I'm slightly biased but those people who
know I'm agrees thank you I'm there's
nothing guy thank you so much thank you
thank you mrs. Kushner for joining us at
the table we appreciate it
Jared you're welcome - any time any time
you still have 32 minutes to make it
over here White House press secretary
it's a little lesson the less about 20
20 minutes Jared Kushner make it over
here